this is comac c919 China's first
homegrown narrow body jet that's been in
the works for more than a decade this is
a 737 Max 8 Boeing's popular narrow body
plane among Airlines worldwide
this type of plane can cover lots of
domestic and InterContinental routes
accounting for more than half of the
global passenger aircraft Fleet
and that's a big reason why Beijing
hopes its own model can compete with
Western giants like Boeing and become
the main carrier at home eventually one
day taking on the global airspace
so we compare the design and Technology
of both planes to see how China's deep
Reliance on Western Parts could sign the
beijing's ambition to challenge its U.S
rival
Boeing has more than 100 years of
experience with commercial Aviation
China in comparison started exploring
the industry in the 1970s but for
several decades wasn't able to develop
its own airliner so Boeing became one of
China's go-to companies in China Boeing
has had a great couple decades Richard
abulafia is managing director with
aerodynamic advisory and Aerospace and
defense consultancy based in Michigan
for more than 30 years he's been
tracking Global Aviation markets with
Boeing as one of his main focuses if you
look back at China economic growth and
air travel demand growth it really took
off in the 90s and sometime in the 2000s
that began to translate into very large
jetliner sales numbers Boeing strutliner
sales hit a record high in 2017. the
American Giant sent more than 200 planes
to China that's about a quarter of all
its deliveries that year it also has a
737 completion and delivery plan there
today about 40 percent of China's
passenger Fleet comes from Boeing with
more than than half of the planes held
by the European giant Airbus which also
has an assembly plant in China so in
order to reduce its Reliance on the two
Western jetliners the Chinese government
has been focused on comac which was
established in 2008 and Chinese
president Xi Jinping has especially been
keen on creating a domestic airliner
um
University
China hasn't revealed how much it's
invested in comac but some Aerospace
analysts estimate that the state-owned
company has received somewhere between
49 and 72 billion dollars in government
Aid that was and is a national goal for
for China to be able to compete against
the U.S and Boeing Alex krutz is
managing director with us-based
Aerospace consulting firm Patriot
industrial partners and he's been
following comex programs for about seven
years ultimately designing and building
a successful commercial our aligner is
is very technologically advanced for
countries to be able to do so to develop
a successful commercial airliner China
has been eyeing Western designs like
Boeing the two jets are both narrow
bodies with a single aisle they're also
about the same size and carry a similar
number of passengers
even the engines aren't too different
they're from CFM which is a joint
venture between General Electric and
Safran of France and they're very
similar engines with roughly similar
levels of Technology both engines are
models from the leap 1 series from CFM
leap 1B is for Boeing leap 1C is for
comac but the max 8 and the c919 need
more than just the engines to take off
they need other systems like the
mechanical mechanical systems landing
gears or Management Systems avionics or
the cockpits these components and their
supply chains have played a big role in
establishing Boeing as an industry
leader over the years with Decades of
experience the American company has
developed steady relationships with its
partners and suppliers at home and
abroad and most of them are close allies
of the US it's very much an
international creation Boeing's major
International Partners Japan Britain
France Canada Italy Germany and many
others those Partnerships have helped
Boeing secure some of the most Advanced
Technologies for its aircraft like the
cockpit which is the brain of the plane
comac also needs a global supply chain
to put the c919 together especially from
American and European companies but
Aerospace analysts say some foreign
suppliers have been reluctant to provide
state-of-the-art components over
concerns about their intellectual
property
this is saddled the c919 with older
technology than the 737 Max 8 and even
the Airbus 320 Neo but this may not be
the biggest risk to the comac project
there's this I guess sword hanging over
the 919 and a lot of it does come down
to geopolitics the U.S has long accused
China as seeking to steal Advanced
Technologies for use in its military
which Beijing repeatedly denied in
January last year the Trump
Administration added comac to a list of
companies that it said supported China's
military curbing the plane
manufacturer's access to American
Technology and funding comac was later
removed from President Biden issued a
new list the Chinese company didn't
respond to a request for comment about
The Blacklist and concerns over IP
infringement as well as whether
geopolitical tensions could pose a risk
to its c919 program
even if these vulnerabilities was
sourcing critical western parts
disappeared Aviation experts say comac
still has other challenges learning how
to build it conforming that is to say
each article is exactly the same as the
previous one that's a major challenge
that's one of the easiest places to
stumble and another stumbling block if
and when China goes Global the lack of a
worldwide support system for operators
to obtain c919 spare parts or receive
maintenance and repairs got to service
it aftermarket support for the airplanes
so there's vast networks that Boeing has
that comac has to develop
for Boeing the U.S giant also has its
own problems especially in the Chinese
market as trade tensions broke out
between the U.S and China in 2017
Beijing froze nearly all orders and
deliveries of Boeing's Plains since
early 2019 the country has also kept the
737 Max grounded after two fatal crashes
in Indonesia and Ethiopia
Boeing says it continues to work with
global regulators and customers to
safely return the 737 Max and seize
China as an important market for the
company's commercial planes urging
dialogue between Beijing and Washington
despite the challenges comac is moving
forward the c919 marked a major
milestone in September towards carrying
passengers and the company has plans to
develop a wide body plane as well but
for comeek to rival Boeing it'll be a
long and perhaps bumpy flight ahead